eu finance and economy ministers will
discuss better ways to help improve
access to funding for small and
medium-sized enterprises in talks in
luxembourg on october 15.
fallout from the crisis and general
economic ill health have created deep
uncertainty in the financial sector with
smes undergrowing financial pressure the
ministers will look at potential risk
sharing instruments like a joint
guarantee scheme for new loans which
would be partly financed with eu money
the decisions are part of preparations
for a meeting of eu heads of state and
government in brussels on the 24th and
25th of october
they'll also pave the way for talks
between the leaders on possible areas
for strengthening economic policy
coordination
also on the agenda in luxembourg is an
exchange of views on the lessons learned
from the european semester process
this helps eu member states to better
monitor their budgets and economic
policies
the aim of the talks is to draw
conclusions from the process in 2013
which ended on july 9 when
country-specific recommendations were
adopted and planned the way ahead for
the next year
the next european semester cycle gets
underway in november when the commission
will publish its annual growth survey
its view of the eu's policy priorities
for 2014.